Ce phénomène cyclique commence quand les eaux chaudes de l'océan Pacifique
occidental tropical se déplacent vers l'Est le long de l'équateur,
en direction des côtes d'Amérique du Sud.
Les eaux de surface chaudes du Pacifique restent alors près des côtes.
- L'augmentation de ces températures dans l'Est du bassin Pacifique,
décale l'activité des pluies dans l'Est du bassin,
donc donne des anomalies de pluies et peut donner des événements
très pluvieux accompagnés d'inondations sur la côte Est de l'Amérique du Sud.
Début janvier, à Soumissionne, les crues ont contraint plus de 150.000 personnes
à abandonner leur foyer.
À différents endroits, la capitale a connu de graves inondations
depuis le mois de novembre.
À la mi décembre, le niveau du fleuve Paraguay avait déjà atteint 6 mètres 50,
son plus haut niveau de toute l'année.
Largement supérieur au seuil déjà critique de 5 mètres 50.
Beaucoup redoutaient le pire.
Des milliers de personnes ont été évacuées des quartiers situés le long
de la rivière quand le niveau du fleuve a atteint les 7 mètres 84, le 7 janvier.
- Chaque fois, la crue est plus intense.
C'est un lieu où le fleuve grandit sans cesse, et dernièrement,
il est devenu incontrôlable.
En décembre, je n'ai pas pu venir jusqu'ici.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai fait un effort pour venir, pour mon père.
Vous voyez, ce n'est pas facile d'accès.
Mais mon père a toute sa vie ici, ses animaux, sa famille.
Il ne veut pas partir.
Près de 6000 familles ont été touchées dans les premières semaines de décembre,
après que le niveau du fleuve a franchi la barre des 7 mètres.
Le nombre des victimes a doublé.
13.000 familles furent victimes des inondations.
La plupart d'entre elles, originaires de Los Banados, le quartier pauvre
de la ville, situé tout proche du fleuve.
Le gouvernement paraguayen déclara l'état d'urgence à Asuncion,
ainsi que dans sept autres régions du pays pareillement affectées.
Le phénomène El Niño se produit de manière aléatoire à peu près tous les deux
à sept ans et durent de 12 à 18 mois,
engendrant des risques répétés d'inondations dans les zones exposées
et la menace de l'épidémie de choléra et de paludisme.
- L'eau, n'est pas allée jusqu'à la maison.
Elle est d'abord montée petit à petit, et puis c'est venu d'un coup.
Ça s'est passé comme ça en 74 ou 75.
Cette année, nous avons été inondés deux fois, l'eau est montée jusqu'au mur.
La marque est arrivée quasiment à 9 mètres.
Nous sommes prêts à rester parce que j'aime ma vie ici.
Le problème, c'est la salle de bain, la lumière et les maladies.
Pas moins de 200 pylônes électriques ont été détruits
par des pluies torrentielles, laissant des milliers de foyers sans électricité.
Quatre personnes ont trouvé la mort, victimes de chutes d'arbres,
dans ce qui fut considéré comme les pires inondations depuis un demi siècle.
Le montant total des dégâts est estimé à 3,5 millions de dollars.